people out here they don't even know the
outside world exists might as well be
living on the moon I ask you something
your Christian yeah no well what do you
believe
I think human consciousness is a tragic
misstep in evolution nature created an
aspect of nature separate from itself we
are creatures that you not exist
I think the honorable thing for our
species to do is stop reproducing walk
hand and hand into extinction
brothers and sisters opting out of a raw
deal
[ __ ] Rus all this dark [ __ ] it's gonna
weigh on your soul man so your soul is
your consciousness your consciousness is
your mind your mind is just a rotting
piece of meat pulsing with blood today
toxifying the dirt surrounding your
grave tomorrow that's a soul Marty
okay Wow he wanted to know and now I'm
begging you to shut the
want some gum gum
a meaningless distraction a piece of
highly processed rubber with the
audacity to call itself wintermint when
it's seen both neither winter nor man
what the wet just asked if you wanted
some gum what the was all that sorry
Jesus Christ oh [ __ ] you know what I
think we passed it will you grab the map
out of the glove box ma'am I ain't gonna
tell you where you're headed or just
need directions only direction we're
headed Marty's to the grave you were
born dead
your mother just forgot to grieve you
okay I get it
you got some negative attitude on
everything huh no I got a negative
attitude about nothing and everything is
nothing so yeah
you son of a [ __ ] just stop listen to
the radio stead of hearing you spout off
that [ __ ] see this knife I suppose yeah
if you like tapping your toe to the
sound of the last great American art
form mourning its own untimely death
just before the mass-media puppeteers
reanimate the rotting limbs for cash and
call it Kenny G you are a nightmare you
know that you are a living nightmare
here
heito the Deaf drunk couldn't consume
his own genius pop prostitutes stroking
a limp dick of repressed America welcome
at Carrow cheese I am Molly and here we
go with the Fargo Tron oh wait let me
guess this is uh like a sneak preview of
their [ __ ] that we're all gonna turn
into after we die because uh hey after
all we're all just farts in the wind
anyway Rus sorry I thought I saw a clue
in that flock of birds
sometimes I see clues and birds bird
clues
alright we gotta figure out how we're
gonna work together rust because right
now I'm about to lose my life
how about this let's just talk about
something like okay I can do like right
that's all I'm asking hey there's some
fluffy white clouds recycled piss
floating just above our heads waiting to
dump down on women and children like
gods golden shower all right how about
ice cream non-consensual milk extraction
turned into a treat that's the first
step on a cobblestone road to type 2
diabetes Sesame Street an actor dreams
of playing Hamlet now dressed like a
giant nerd sunshine melanoma rainbow red
blood orange flame yellow yellow king
green and the blue depression violet
violence oh you you forgot indigo indigo
girls they said poppies that is yeah you
got anything to say about adorable sweet
little puppies yeah I got a thing on
Bobbie oh you have something to say
about puppies I got some money well then
just lay it on me Ross you want to hear
my thing up up tell me your thing on
puppies Ross here comes rest Cole's
musing on puppies just tell me your
thing on puppies in three two one of
these creatures so feeble that they
stopped evolving and opted to rather be
shepherded by a superior species you
think they love you but don't be fooled
the second you pass out in your kitchen
they're gonna eat your
and [ __ ] it out of their tiny exposed
[ __ ] just the belly spawn of curs
and [ __ ] blasted out like a dump load
of mulch on this earth before the runts
are devoured by the mother while they're
still wet with Lassonde
burpees
shoot I wish you'd asked me about
confetti love confetti need a hug